[Music]
at Hollywood these companies have been
there for a long time Fox Universal
Disney Steven making entertainment
product for a long time and now you have
in Silicon Valley companies have been
around for a very short period of time
the Facebook's the instagrams the
snapchats and the question is you know
where are we going to be in the decades
to come
are those studios still going to be out
there making films the way they've been
doing for a long time and with these new
companies be continuing what they're
going to do where they get a morph into
something else the technology is amazing
and people love it and they love IMAX
and they love VR and they love all the
stuff that's coming along next however
you know people watch movies on their
iPhones you know and if you're making a
film and you know you spend all this
time working on it and you know
someone's going to live on you feel like
well jeez you know it's most timely
worrying about the lighting and the
camera move and they're watching on
iPhone but that's the reality of the
world that we're in and that's why I
think story is still still king here I
watch this IMAX film about climbing up
Everest and it was filmed you know
spectacularly well and I thought it was
was pretty boring and then there's a
scene there that's amazingly powerful
where somebody um says goodbye their
wife that they're dying on the mountain
and it was filmed with this very cheap
camera and that's you know that's what
was moving I mean that's what made the
film memorable
you think to remember about soakin
values is the technology is everywhere
here you know the sort of the joke is if
you're not paying for the product you
are the product and so there's an
amazing amount of data that's out there
about what you do but they're places
that data can't really penetrate and and
part of what makes films films is you
can't just look at the data if someone
could have figured out a formula for
predicting movie success they would have
done a long time ago would have been
game over there still is something that
comes from you know the heart and the
brain and that you try to come up with
something creative that engages an
audience and wants them to hang in with
your story and wants them to forget
about you know the sort of the soccer
game where they lost or the fact that
their knee hurts or they got a rush home
for the babysitter that they get swept
into the you know the part of the story
and you know when you make a film
there's some really rewarding parts of
that I mean there's moments when you're
making a film where you feel like the
information you're seeing is powerful
and it's touching and you hope that you
know you have the skills and the
technical abilities and the creative
abilities to bring that to an audience
and if you're effective when you're
doing an interview in a documentary film
and you look around and your entire crew
is crying that they're moved by story
and you're crying as well because
someone's telling you such a powerful
story you say to yourself oh my god you
know I hope that one day a movie theater
full of people will be just as affected
or they'll watch it on TV and be
affected and that is like one-to-one
personal storytelling where the
filmmakers trying to make a connection
with the audience but then you hope it
goes to a wide audience and that people
also have an emotional connection
we're in a situation now where you had a
film at Sundance that came out this year
that was gonna on the iPhone the
oscar-winning documentary searching for
sugar man was shot partially at an
iPhone
I mean audiences have shown this kind of
willingness to embrace you know things
shot and cheap technology if the story
is compelling you know what does it make
you start watching a minute one and go
two minute five and stay all the way in
there you need a compelling story where
people you care about it needs to be in
movies that you could sort of trick
people into going to see a movie so you
could spend lavishly on newspaper and TV
ads and by the time you know people
realize the film was terrible is already
a hit well now it's hard to do that now
you know people go into theaters so the
movie doesn't seem that good on Friday
night they're busy you know sending
texts or going on Facebook and I think
it hurts you know over publicise bad
movies but also helps under publicize
good movies so if you look at Pixar that
is a beautiful marriage because right
it's technologically sophisticated great
and the storytelling is first-rate and
the way they work together is in a
highly collaborative way and that's
everything working really well and so I
think you're going to see more of these
examples coming forward as people sort
of admire the Pixar way and and it's I
think that inevitably
the two sides going to become closer
it's my strong belief that this is a
marriage of Silicon Valley in Hollywood
sometimes they're suspicious of each
other sometimes I don't quite understand
each other but we really need each other
I mean we're we're sitting right now in
the heart of Silicon Valley is where
products are designed that's where you
know the cutting-edge truly is on the
other hand you know when you're watching
on your iPhone or your iPad or your
laptop or however you're watching
there's got to be content on that and
there's not that much content that's
coming out of Northern California the
content is coming primarily out of
Southern California and those are
stories that have to be well told and I
think there's this idea that you know
both sides can learn from the other side
you know and I think that with this
marriage you're going to see
increasingly better better shows better
delivered especially as an audience has
come to embrace this idea that audiences
just want good content and they don't
really care where it's coming from they
will go to where the content is good
[Music]